la voilà elle est enfin apparu devant
une foule en liesse quatre jours que les
britanniques la célèbre malgré son
absence elle est arrivée sur le fameux
balcon de buckingham palace entouré de
sa garde rapprochée que son fils le
futur roi et le prince william le
deuxième dans l'ordre de succession
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis le célèbre god save the queen suivi
d'un feu d'artifice aux couleurs de
l'union jack
dans un communiqué elle remercie des
britanniques il n'y a pas de précédent
pour célébrer 70 ans de rennes
écrit-elle je n'ai pas pu participer aux
festivités mais mon coeur était avec
vous tous et je continuerai à vous
servir de mon mieux
c'est le carrosse doré vieux de deux
cent soixante ans qui a ouvert la parade
le même que la jeune elizabeth ii a pris
lors de son couronnement ya 70 ans
pendant deux heures un défilé d'abord
militaire puis artistique reflétant les
différentes périodes de l'histoire de la
grande-bretagne aux premières loges le
prince charles et sa femme camilla
entouré du prince william et de sa
famille un défilé haut en couleurs
représentant chaque décennie oui à la
[Musique]
rigueur
une journée rythmée par des pique niques
à travers tout le pays à windsor on a
aligné 488 table sur l'allée menant au
château
mais le clou des festivités a été le
concert de samedi soir et c'est la reine
avec le célèbre son trading tonnes qui a
donné la première note
ce jubilé a révélé une reine frêle qui
est à la fin de son règne et qui prépare
sa succession
elle souhaite que l'unité autour de la
couronne se poursuivre pendant des
années avec ou sans elle ici à 0 2 les
guerres guise radio-canada londres